okay so my name is Sebastian and I work
for the our group in Boston and we're
busy implementing a neural network
framework so this talk will be give a
high-level overview of some things that
first of all applications of neural
networks and why they're interesting and
why they're so hot currently and then
I'll give an overview of an actual case
study of how we built in identifiers so
all the steps that are required to do
something like that
and then the ends we'll discuss quickly
what's coming in either 10.4 11.04 the
new neural network framework okay so the
first thing is yeah what can you do with
neural networks and why are they so
popular so the most basic thing you can
do is simple classification and
regression and we've really got that
actually in the system and classify and
predicts and the thing we've got in
classify and predict is the simplest
type in your network where you have some
inputs in this case there's three
dimensional inputs so each of these
nodes corresponds to one of the features
these features get connected up to a
hidden layer and there's some weights
that tell it like how strong this
connection should be so you for each of
these guys and the signal then gets
propagated for words and you have some
output in this case there's two things
that's either true or false so this is
the most basic type of network and these
were already in existence in the 60s and
people were training them with back
propagation which is basically just
getting the derivative of the last
function with respect to all the weights
so this is a very ancient technology but
it works very well
well 60 is for me it's an ancient
technology okay so that's a basic thing
then this specialist networks however
for things like images so identify this
is a basic example of this the network
looks something like this
each of these these pointer is so
previously these are actual neurons
however you can abstract this to be a
single layer this whole thing so when
there's lots and lots of layers you have
something that looks like this and the
input comes in and it gets fed through
this whole network and each of these
modules here are different types of
things that are specialized for images
the main the main operation is a
convolution and convolutions they give
the network all kinds of interesting
properties like Minh some translation
and variants for example that you know
images should have etc etc so these are
the very deep neural networks that I
like yeah like 20 layers deep or they go
up to 30 to 40 layers so this is yeah
this was in 2012 this was the big
revolution that got sparks when neural
networks came back into fashion and that
was for image recognition and on this
famous competition called
image nets you have like a million
images that you had can train on and as
like a thousand classes that you have to
predict and previous methods used all
kinds of handcrafted features and then
feeding them into support vector
machines and a 2012 neural networks just
completely destroyed all the previous
attempts of this competition so okay so
this is a very basic yeah basic use case
that we've we've used a lot and you can
also have some fun with these networks
so this is something that I generated
with image identifiers and you can ask
it basically you can say what things so
you can say at this level that say
listen listener on here what sort of
images activates these neurons the most
so you can change the image gradually to
activate the neurons the most and it
generally corresponds to things that's
it seen the most of in training so our
training set for birds is extremely big
so whenever this thing starts seeing
things it sees a lot of buildings and it
sees a lot of birds sure yeah so as you
saw with some image that is it can be
random image it can be in this case
yeah just like some scene of some sky
and some lawn and then you let it go and
you say what how do you maximize the
activations of some layer of this
network and then yeah you just change
the image to make it more like that okay
so the second major class of of networks
so these four images and for for this
classification regression in general
they call feed-forward neural networks
and what that means is that the signal
gets propagated continuously for it we
know they're in the brain and for yeah
for other neural systems that there's
feedback loops as well so for things
like sequence prediction you have to
have some sort of feedback loop so you
want to have you want to show it some
character then you want to have some
states get passed back into the network
rerun into the next sequence of the
character at cetera cetera so I've got a
very simple example here which we
trained up to see so this yeah so it's a
very simple model it predicts the next
character in some sequence so you can
start it off with some initial sequence
and then it finds the conditional
probabilities of the secret of the
characters that come up to this and it
does it again and again so it finds the
next character then the next one it
cetera cetera so in this case we can try
run this a bit and see if this works
so okay so I generated like 70
characters and I started with though has
strong so it says well have strong the
and I will take them to the gods to him
okay not a lot completely perfect
grammatically but it's predicting yeah
it has no concept of words in this case
it's just predicting the next characters
and you can also have longer sentences
that you can generate from scratch yeah
train on some sub some set of his works
you can also do things like codes so
well yeah we train this on some amount
of Wolfram language codes and you can
generate yeah arbitrary amounts of what
it thinks is correct code which is
usually well which breaks down at some
point quite quickly and you can start
this off yeah whatever you want or just
randomly initialize it I don't know
what's what this I should do this might
be bad oh no what is that okay that's
the bits these are current your networks
as that's they takin some inputs or like
in this case it's a character and they
passed the state of the network to the
next time step and then you pass the
next carrot in and you have a single set
of weights that you use each time step
and that's very important if you have
too many weights then it just learning
can happen really at all okay so what
becomes very interesting is when you
starts merging different types of
networks so here's one example so
there's a lot of research and making
image captioning work and image
captioning is actually very simple so
you just have a deep convolutional
neural network which is just a feed for
words and the features or the the end of
the network gets fed into a recurrent
neural network which then has to start
predicting words and this is an extra
output of Google's image captioner so
yeah it has a picture of a market and it
produces multiple sentences describing
what's in the market it's not a so the
sequences okay so it takes in two things
so it takes in feature for the image so
it takes in a single vector of numbers
and then it needs to predict so you've
got when you train this thing you've got
correct labels or labels that humans
have made so it then needs to take that
as a starting point and then
generates a sentence and there's some
scoring function that you can use to see
how good's the sentences compared to
human generated senses okay then it's
been a lot of research now also on
things like question answering so for
example there's a famous data set that a
Facebook is just released it's called
Bobby and this is sort of the example of
this like John moves the bedroom Mary
grab football the Sandra journey to the
bedroom son right back to the hallway
Mary moved to the garden mary journey to
the office where's the football and new
or never because I've gotten very good
at this sort of question answering you
can train them yeah
I'm just lots of data and then I'm
completely unseen textual yeah logic
problems they do fairly well and there's
yeah Facebook develops a special kind of
network that has some extra memory cells
on it as well but it's completely yeah
it just fits into the the normal natural
framework and then obviously you can
also then say what about having a
question on string system for images so
this also there's been a lot of recent
activity for this so yeah you go to a
picture and it outputs you things like
yeah you can ask its what kind of store
is it is the display case as well as
could be
anyway this yeah you can ask it any
kinds of questions and people are busy
trying to build bigger and bigger data
sets of questions that they're collected
from the internet so the biggest data
set currently has like 15 million
answers for questions on images there
ain't so so this is a very interesting
application actually building one of
these things at the moment okay these
are just like a that's just a taste of
things that's that you can do with
neural networks it's also newer networks
on the the current state of the art and
a whole bunch of other tasks i'm speech
recognition we're busy building out and
speech recognition system to OCR to
video understanding to a whole bunch of
interesting yeah random things like
counting the number of people in the
crowds yeah what are these these tasks
are like neuro networks of
have basically no competitors for okay
except speech recognition actually
there's a okay so I want to give a quick
example of yeah of just how you actually
go about building a system based on a
neural network and a large scale or
let's say classifier so in this case
image ad Phi so how do you go about
something like this so the first thing
is you want to get almost all the visual
categories in the world so it's a huge
task to get your own data sets for that
to build your own data set so we started
with image net so image net is a very
famous data set it's having Stanford's
as one of the group's that's that built
it and it was a semi-automated way of
building this thing so it had some yeah
some curation innards but mostly it was
just scraped from the internet yeah it
has 14 million images like 20,000
categories and the idea of image net is
that it's hierarchical so you have right
at the bottom the hierarchy but very
specific things and then you've got
things high up the hierarchy like a
bicycle is much more specific than a
mountain bike so we wanted to focus on
predicting the leaves of the thing so
the button pieces and then poke a little
then get the probability of each of
these guys and then you can get the
probabilities of all the higher things
on the tree okay so that seems very easy
simple done however it turns out that
this data set is of terrible quality so
some weird things like they've got some
bizarre categories of images things like
wandering jew and they've got a picture
of Bob Dylan there's an example of the
wandering jew and you can check this on
the website oh yeah for the snake so
that's one sort of thing it's like just
bizarre categories that are not really
visualizable and that you don't want in
a system like this and will be very
embarrassing like if yeah for a user
instead of person that returns something
like this
so the second sort of piece that was
annoying was certain carries a
completely incorrect so the scrapings as
an example of this the shuttle so the
actual definition of the chateau for
this particular word nets thing is a
bobbin that passes the weft threads
between the warp threads so it's a
sewing term but all the pictures are
basically pictures of space shuttles so
this is just two examples the most
common case though is just that there's
many incorrect images in yeah in the in
the classes and especially for things
that are very specific so they've got
very specific animal types as well and
barn types and these you can imagine
like yeah things go wrong there so the
question is what do you do it with this
like this is huge mess oh yeah 20
thousands of these sunset of the captive
categories and you have these 14 million
images you can't go through all the
images it's impossible but you're not
going to get anything done that curation
will take too long for that however
curation is yeah is a builder solution
but you have to be clever about it so
the first thing most basic step is that
you can curates what the cat good there
what the good categories are for an
image recognition system the second
thing then is he finds what categories
you're missing so this was the thing
that is this is a very hard thing to
discover that you're missing some
category so we did all kinds of things
like I remembered going around my house
and getting my family to take photos of
all the things that can possibly sear on
their house and try and get the
recognizer to see these things and then
try and catch categories of things that
become Kiki just weren't in this thing
with certain categories of things like
weird things like like soap for example
some are there is no images in the soap
category and how do you catch that
because your test said weren't catch it
for easily because there's test set yeah
it has no there's nothing in there so
but the most vexing one was certain
categories were just completely
polluters like something like 70% of the
images are wrong
and sometimes grossly wrong so the way
to solve a problem like this that we
found in the end was that you have a
continuous feedback loop between the
classifier and the curators so the
classifier you train this thing up and
then you can see on the test side what
are we failing at what categories is
confusing with other categories and then
those ones you sent to the curators to
say is there a problem here
so we'd identify every day there's
something like 200 categories of objects
that's we think that the classifier
things might be kind of might be getting
confused with other things so this went
on for yeah for like two weeks or so and
we managed to clean up a lot of the
stuff and as soon as ya categorize Bad's
the curators would go in and just focus
on a category you take out the bad
images and maybe you find some extra
images as well a fist a few phone okay
the second thing then is another thing
is okay so from this is this graph you
should see now one of the big challenges
was speed so this alex net this was the
state of the art circa 2012 this was
Hinton's winning solution for image net
2012 and it's very fast to train in
modern terms so the one that the network
we eventually settled on for training
which won last year is image net
competition what's a variation of that
one that takes much longer to train in
this roughly a factor like it was the
fact it eight or so slower so if you
have a CPU so this is a okay so there's
a framework called cafe these benchmarks
come from there so it's one of those
popular image classification frameworks
and has both GPU and CPU modes and even
on a very high-end CPU 16 cores yawn for
this fairly simple network it takes 43
days and this thing was so this was only
for a million images we were dealing
with many more so yeah so we had a much
slower Network and we had many more
images of the images and I were used for
image net competition so CPU just
cle-cle it was not not in the question
so the only thing that you can really do
is is use GPUs and we also had multiple
GPUs I'll show this now
so also just for interests the GPU is
I'm the GPU arms race just keeps on
going faster and faster and like next
year and videos promised us a 10 a
factor 10 speed-up over the current
state-of-the-art using various tricks
from 16 points precision for the neural
networks it's been seen that you don't
need more than 16 bit floats so a whole
bunch of other interest memory and
acceleration and faster connection
between different GPUs etc so there's
more more power coming very very quickly
so I mean yeah so currently this the
best thing you can do and which we
bought for this project was this sort of
machine it has four Titan X GPUs each of
them has roughly seven teraflop floating
points yeah power and you can paralyze
across four of these guys so this is
basically as much computing that you can
get from a power from a single power
socket so okay so then this is one thing
so also there was a whole bunch of
things to get so we were also constantly
getting new data I closer to the release
and we had to update the networks so
there was a bunch of tricks as well to
prevent retraining the whole thing again
and again so you can fine tune them
otherwise it would take far too long to
retrain these things again and again
okay then there's a whole bunch of other
things so for a production system you
have to be very careful of there's
certain constraints that you want to
have so for a competition like image
nerds all you care about its accuracy
but then as soon as you can start caring
about other things like how long does it
take to evaluate for the user how big is
it on disk so one of the best networks
last year an image net was Oxford groups
Network and it's like 600 megabytes just
a store the thing and it takes something
like 17 times longer than to evaluate
than our current implementation
so there's a whole bunch of compromises
and we found that a variation on Google
net was was the best it's very small it
has almost as good performance as the
other one and it's fairly fast to
evaluate and there's a whole bunch of
other modifications that yeah we played
with to improve the performance of the
original Google heads implementation so
tricks that came after this competition
again so what's coming so by 10 points
for 11.0 we expect to have some
framework for training neural networks
we it's designed to be used by our group
for research and for other groups in the
company so it's designed to be extremely
powerful and flexible and user tweakable
but it's also designed to be very very
easy to use so we have a type inference
system that Taliesin has made that means
that you don't have to give almost any
parameters in your network it went for
all the correct dimensions all the
layers etc etc if you don't want to so
even a very beginner I can just string
together a bunch of these these layers
and it'll know exactly it won't give you
throw you crazy
error messages like other platforms like
cafe etc it will also obviously have GPU
support suppose you want to use this
internally for a search and our users
want to have GPU support for this and
currently yeah it's by far the fastest
thing to do if you have large data sets
so other things like that will add some
currently for machine learning there's a
few things we lacking so things like
sequence prediction we're lacking very
valiant so this framework will support
recurring your networks and STM's etc
and you can string these very easy
together with convolutional networks
that do things like the image caption
generator of example so those all the
examples that I showed you those are
things that we aim to be able to
implement very very easily in the
Wolfram language and we will have our
example showing how to do that another
thing that all machine learning
framework doesn't currently have there's
any out-of-court learning
so for datasets that are bigger than
that fit into memory like huge image
data sets this thing supports that for
images and for a few of things then okay
so eventually we're also not allowed GPU
training on the bull from language cloud
and this will make it very very easy to
do training you don't have to set up
your own GPU machine and there's well
obviously optimize it very we can
optimize it as much as possible for the
exact GP machines we've gone in the
cloud and it'll be very easy to deploy
the thing it'll be yeah it'll just be a
one of the easiest ways of training
neural networks and yeah we're trying to
keep so currently there's a huge amount
of research in the neural networks and
there's just constantly innovations on
different layer types that you can put
into these networks to improve image
classification performance or whatever
else and yeah we try and one of those we
one of those for research for ourselves
we obviously will implement the latest
things I can't so yeah so that is what's
coming hopefully in the next version